La France Agricole ne peut pas se passer
de continuer à échanger qui imagine
demain la viticulture concentrée sur le
marché national c'est sa fin programmée
et immédiate qui imagine que sur le
champ des céréales à un moment où on est
dans une bataille géopolitique avec
notamment la Russie et l'Ukraine sur le
continent africain on puisse passer de
la production et puis je pourrais vous
parler des produits laitiers transformés
et d'un certain nombre de d'autres
produits par ailleurs comme toujours
avoir des intérêts offensifs et
défensifs et c'est vrai que sur les
intérêts qu'on souhaite protéger on a
notamment la question de l'élevage je
faudrais en dire un mot parce que c'est
évidemment
central notamment dans les sujets de
planification écologique tout le monde
nous dit que la prairie quelque chose
d'essentiel puisque sur le plan de la
biodiversité sur le plan du carbone
c'est un levier important mais par
ailleurs on constate tous les jours que
conserver notamment des bovins que ce
soit en lait ou en viande c'est
compliqué pour les éleveurs et je le dis
il y a quand même un moment où on pourra
pas avoir des prairies d'un côté et rien
à mettre dessus ça n'a pas la la prairie
a une fonctionnalité c'est de nourrir un
troupeau voilà et donc du coup euh il y
a tout un tas de de de sujets qui qui
qui se posent sur cette question là un
moment où où ça décapitalise beaucoup
voilà donc ces conditions d'échange qui
prévoi qu'on puisse importer notamment
de la viande bovine mais je vous pourra
vous parler des ovins dans des
conditions de réciprocité qui
questionnent le monde agricole interroge
je le dis c'est pour ça que j'essaie de
rester équilibré devant vous en disant
on peut avoir des intérêts offensifs et
il y en a dans d'autres secteurs mais ce
qu'on constate c'est que souvent dans
les accords commerciaux la question
agricole vis-à-vis des pays avec lequels
on on veut passer les accords la
question de l'agriculture est souvent
une monnaie d'échange l'Europe est
plutôt exportatrice de biens et services
de produits manufacturés et et les
produits qui veulent signer avec nous
les pays qui veulent signer avec nous
des accords on plutôt de de de des
produits agricoles ou tous les cas du
secteur primaire amener donc il faut
qu'on on le regarde